hello well today i'm talking to jeremy
who has a youtube channel called
motivate korean
[Music]
hi there steve goffman here today's
video is an interview i did with uh
jeremy who is uh
an american who lives in korea who
teaches korea and i think a little bit
of english as well
uh but before getting into that
i wanted to mention
that uh
next well my 90 day arabic challenge
ends at the end of this month so
december the 1st 10 o'clock
vancouver time pacific standard time
we're going to try to organize a live
stream where i'm going to talk to
muhammad from egypt from cairo
but it would be fun if some people out
there if you are native speakers of
arabic and you'd like to participate we
maybe could have two or three people
also in this sort of zoom conference
and asking me questions or talking about
stuff and we can talk about anything we
can talk about
travel or
politics or how to use link or whatever
people want to talk about
so anyway here is the uh the interview
with jeremy i did one for his channel as
well
uh the subject is this whole issue of
obstacles to learning
language obstacles
cultural obstacles and i have to say
that
in my experience you just keep going and
these obstacles just fade away and
one shouldn't get too hung up on
apparent obstacles of course it's
difficult at first and the better you
get
the lower the obstacles are anyway
here's the interview i did with jeremy
and remember next uh tuesday or at least
if you're interested in if you're a
native speaker of arabic and you want to
get on and speak only standard arabic uh
you know don't try on with with the
local variants of arabic
uh you know let me know here or
somewhere and uh
it's uh gerene of our group is going to
organize and i don't know how we'll
select randomly uh two or three people
arabic speakers to participate in the
live stream okay and for the rest of you
you can all watch it and you can send in
questions but we may only have a few
people actually you know live on the on
the zoom conference okay then uh and now
here's the main uh the main interview
and in fact he can explain the details
of his different presence on on the
internet but i like two things one that
he's talking about korean which is a
language that i'm interested in and he's
focused on motivation so jeremy can you
introduce yourself and tell us a bit
about who you are where you are and your
activities sure
um
who i am first my name is jeremy
excuse me my name is jeremy uh i'm from
california united states
i
i grew up in a very multicultural
environment i had a lot of friends from
different countries and i heard
different languages as a kid and i was
always a little bit sort of jealous of
them and i thought it was just so cool
like magic power that they had to be
able to
understand and speak these other
languages and so
i didn't really get started learning
languages though until i was in my 20s
after i finished my schooling
although i learned a little bit of
spanish in school and
i've studied korean quite extensively
obviously that's what i teach and
talk about on my youtube channel and i
also do a podcast called spongemind
as well
in korean and english the podcast
and it's all focused on language
learning so i've dedicated my work life
to helping other language learners stay
on the path
i've also taught english to korean
people for almost 10 years
usually through one-on-one not in group
settings so i've worked with individual
people and i found that motivation is
usually at the crux of all issues and we
just filmed the video for my channel as
well steve and i and we he discussed
that as well how motivation is one of
the biggest factors or probably the
biggest factor and how well the learning
goes of a language so i'm sure we may
discuss that here
so what what are
the factors that motivate people to
learn korean
and what can you do to
sustain that motivation explain that
good question well the
the reason i started my channel was
because i had a i was living in korea i
had moved to korea with no knowledge of
korean just the the alphabet basically
and i went there with a few of my
friends from college
and or university i should say and we
went together and we all were just
gung-ho about learning korean and we all
got into it and then very quickly they
started to fall off after a month or two
and
and i saw everyone around me even people
who had lived there for a long time they
just started to they just quit
and when i asked them and discussed it i
realized a lot of times it was some sort
of misunderstanding whether it be
cultural the korean people often laugh
at when we make pronunciation mistakes
which is very rude in our culture but
not
necessarily rude to them so there was a
lot of these misunderstandings that
would sort of knock people off the path
and then also in terms of the learning
activities that they do they were either
doing it wrong or not wrong but very
inefficiently
and uh and doing things that were not
fun for them or as we discussed in the
last video steve the using materials
that were very dry and boring to them
and so for for one of those reasons they
usually ended up quitting and so i
thought well if i could just
make videos about things that are
helping people to get past these hurdles
to clear the path so to speak go through
the jungle with a big machete and cut
down all the branches that are in the
way that kind of thing then maybe more
people would continue to walk on the
path
and so that's what i've been doing my
videos are they kind of hover around
sometimes more emotional things
frustration and how to get rid of
frustration cultural differences why
korean people do this and that or
linguistic frustrations you know this
thing doesn't mean the same as the
english word and that's why you're using
it wrong and people laugh when you say
it and
yes there are these habits in in
different languages the sort of the
idiosyncrasies of the language
and certainly we are
you know we tend to be influenced by our
native language things that we're used
to in our native language
and even people
who speak english very well say germans
will say
uh you know i have been living in in the
united states since many years which is
wrong of course it's four many years
swedes who speak english very well they
do the same it is many people in china
instead of their army so habits like
that are difficult to change russian i
mean the idea that you know you've got
one verb for going
go come back versus go and stay or go on
a bus
to get
theoretically you can understand this
but when you actually go to speak to try
to actually do that it takes a lot of
practice and exposure
so to me if i think about chinese
japanese
arabic you know i don't speak arabic
well but certainly russians you just get
used to it i don't see that the fact
that
korean has some unique ways of
communicating is in itself not unique to
me unless there is something uniquely
unique about korean which which may be
well maybe i don't have the wide variety
the wide you know diverse experience
with many languages that you do so i
can't necessarily comment on that but
i've talked to thousands of people over
the years about korean and then about
other languages that they speak so we've
compared in that way so right from a you
know third person perspective i i've
seen that
i think that this is the the crux of it
i know there are inconsistencies how do
you overcome if if that is the case and
that's demotivating to people what can
you do then to motivate them yeah okay
i'll lead to that so
uh i believe the issue and with those
examples there are similar ones in
spanish and i i noticed many of those
things false cognates and things like
that grammatical peculiarities the
subjunctive tense tenses that we don't
just don't really have in english so
it's hard to think in them
subjunctive is still quite difficult for
me i'm at that phase
but
with sp with uh with korean the issue is
that these inconsistencies are so
systematic that they pervade almost
every single sentence that you say in a
spoken context and as a result it makes
every step of the the process of
learning heavier or more difficult like
trudging through a swamp than than say
other languages where you have you know
cognates and something to stand on so
i'd say that that's that's the first one
and the demotivating factor about it
is i would say i guess cultural because
korean korean people are very
in group out group there's a very strong
polarity between in-group and out group
in the korean peninsula is roughly like
half the size of florida as far as i've
seen but there are 50 million people or
more there that's about a sixth of the
united states in population
and in that tiny land mass if you drive
two hours they speak very very
differently if you drive three hours
people can't even communicate with each
other uh clearly and if you go to jeju
island native you know people from seoul
actually just cannot speak to them what
at all it's a different dialect it's not
not far away in terms of land
but there's extreme differences in from
city to city and how people speak much
more than say you and i were from
different countries you you grew you
lived on the in the opposite side of the
continent and we have no problems
communicating whatsoever um but that is
not the case with korea yeah
excuse me europe is similar
yeah very good example they have very
very different languages in that regard
within germany italy oh within okay and
i see that as well but the way that this
intersects with the issue that i was
just describing is that right when you s
constantly make
english sounding sentences
that sound like direct translations you
alienate yourself from the group so say
there's a group of five koreans and you
you constantly are almost asserting that
you're an outsider when you make those
errors and they
subconsciously and as a result of
cultural you know
you know things that they've learned
throughout their life
they start to see you as the outsider
and so sometimes they may sort of subtly
ignore you or not include you in certain
aspects of the conversation assuming
that you won't get it and so there's a
long battle from the intermediate to to
i'd say high-level face
where you're really just trying to speak
like a korean person and in order to do
that you have to think like a korean
person and this takes many many many
more hours than
then might with another language where
you share cultural
you know in the west we are very
individualistic so we see you as an
individual and i'm an individual so we
respect each other and i don't force you
to do things you don't want to do and
such and such but in korean you are seen
as a part of the group so there's almost
prerequisites to being korean that
english speakers don't have and so they
could learn the language even to a very
high level even those who speak on tv
and media and stuff in korean i've seen
them speak they often will use very
english-sounding expressions
korean-americans as well and it sort of
alienates them and so they start to get
strange you know there's this there's
static in the communication it's not
clear and i've reached a point now where
uh that is not the case anymore but i
also have korean parents essentially my
in-laws who i speak to all the time who
have parented me in the language in that
way and i have friends and such so i've
been able through
uh you know i'm very lucky in that way
to have made it through that so your
motive you would motivate the learner by
telling them
you just gotta stay the course and
you'll eventually get better is or are
there tricks or other bits of advice
that you have on yeah i help people
overcome these problems i have a game
that i've invented for english speakers
to play and they can play it with their
english-speaking friends who don't care
about korean at all
i just call it korean english
or korean game you know for for
simplicity but it's kind of like
speaking like yoda so i say put the
verbs at the end of the sentence and
drop the pronouns that's it those are
the only two
two
rules of the game but if you play this
game with english speakers
that mental those mental gymnastics are
what you have to do all the time when
you're speaking korean put the verb at
the end and drop the pronoun put the
verb at the end drop the pronoun it's
almost like if you can create that habit
or strengthen that muscle then if it
becomes automatic then when you speak
korean you get very much used to that
and you have a leg up on and it actually
will speed up your
your ability to comprehend and produce
accurate or realistic korean native like
okay any other bits of advice like that
special techniques that you favor in
terms of
um learning korean or language learning
in general things that you tell your
viewers yeah
i talk a lot about repetitive listening
for that reason and i what i have done i
did this with spanish as well is i would
take a one audio file from anything from
it depends on your level so your lower
level shorter audio higher level longer
audio and i would listen to it every day
just automatically whenever i wash the
dishes whenever i commute to and from
work or whenever i'm doing some sort of
physical but rather mundane task
vacuuming whatever
and i'll just only put that on that's
all i listen to i don't listen to music
i have that one file and me and that
file are just together for a while and i
uh i sort of think of it like gum some
files you'll chew some gum you'll chew
and the flavor goes away quickly so you
can change quickly other ones you chew
it and it's got sort of a deeper flavor
and you and you keep going with it and
you keep chewing it and chewing and
chewing it
and eventually what that led me to was
choosing my personality in korean so i
found one speaker who has lots of
content on on youtube of a professional
speaker and i listened only to his
content so i started picking up his his
wording his way of thinking and when i
hit you know things that i didn't
understand i would ask native friends or
i'd try to look it up or i'd use voice
to text to to try to see what the
spelling turned and turned out to be
and i would mine this
content after having downloaded the
audio onto my internal hard drive and it
allowed me to skip the study process
sort of and these words were already
mine a part of me by the time i got the
meaning
two two questions sure first of all can
you provide me the name of that person
i i totally agree
that listening repetitively to a person
to a voice to content that we like where
there's a resonance is extremely
effective yes and i have been looking
for that kind of voice in korean without
my success
so i'd be very interested in in finding
out the name of the chair
and second of all you mentioned in our
conversation for your channel that you
are a proponent of listening to things
that you don't understand
yes no how does that work
uh i'll start with his name his name is
kim chang
so like the ch one chang ok
with the kyok
i can send it to you later kim tango
okay thank you
he might put it in the description box
here too we'll put links to your channel
and we'll put his name in the
description box okay yeah
he's he talks about a lot of life
related topics so um sort of helping
people get over issues emotional issues
and things like that but as a result he
tells stories about so and so doing this
and that there's a variety of content
very much spoken he's from jeju island
and he moved to seoul so he himself has
sort of learned standard korean so he's
kind of a language learner of sorts in
that way so he's a little bit more
linguistically aware very funny just i
find myself bursting out laughing even
when i'm repetitively listening to the
same video i literally laugh at the same
interesting joke
um i also i didn't use transcripts i
never used transcripts he didn't have
them but i was at a level when i started
that i didn't need that necessarily so i
recommend you're not opposed to
listening to stuff that you don't
understand yeah so moving on to that
question uh
i've
i find now again it's very different at
each level a complete beginner i
wouldn't recommend the same thing if
they did this they'd pick up on you know
cadences and intonation patterns
melodies sort of of the language they
may be drawn to words that are said
twice like
is a very common thing that's said twice
so people might pick up on those things
in the beginning phase but after you get
a basis for grammar
you and you listen to something say
to give a number anywhere from 30 to 100
times and this is over the course of a
week or two or sometimes a month so it's
not just all in one sitting because your
brain needs to process it there's there
is digestion that needs to happen
i find that with things that i don't
understand those become sound bites that
get stuck in my head i was just
listening to a song in greek on on
repeat recently just to try this there
are words in there that i can repeat uh
you know or that i could repeat to
someone and ask them the meaning of them
and so there are
sound they become sounds that become
familiar you can also become familiar
with the sound of a certain bird or an
animal or a kind of car you know
hydraulic brakes as the as the bus
passes by you learn to associate a sound
based on repetition with a certain thing
or meaning you give it meaning after the
fact so i i have utilized sound first
then meaning
um and utilize that method and and it's
been very helpful i find that things
that i don't know what they mean at all
entire sentences sometimes will
actually sometimes in conversation they
will fly out of my mouth i will use them
accurately in the context everyone
laughs but later on i can be like what
does that actually mean but i'm using it
in the right context so i'm letting my
subconscious drive
the drive the speaking or drive the
learning more so than my conscience
because i found that it was frustrating
that way interesting well i think
there's a lot there and there's
obviously a lot more uh at your youtube
channel yes
we're gonna leave links in the
description box and people can go and
explore it's been a very interesting
conversation yeah thank you and i will
get back to my korean and so i look
forward to getting the name that person
and
hopefully we can have another
conversation maybe in korean one day
yeah please let me know okay
jeremy thank you very much
thank you bye everyone
[Music]